Pixar's superfamily The Incredibles are
back in a longer weighted sequel that's
bursting with Easter eggs references and
secret cameos yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and today I'm breaking
down the top 30 Pixar superhero and
pop-culture Easter eggs you might have
missed in Incredibles 2 and what that
post-credits teaser means through
Incredibles 3 I'm also starting a new
Incredibles giveaway you just need to be
a subscriber and leave a comment below
about the movie to enter spoilers ahead
so take care if you haven't seen the
film yet a 1 1 3 is a regular Pixar
Easter Egg that's Anna Marsh at the
California Institute of the Arts
classroom where many of Pixar's
animators studied and it pops up
multiple times and Incredibles 2 it
appears on the runaway monorail that
Elastigirl stops it's also the number of
the room where Elastigirl watches a
screen slavers broadcast it's also on
the side of the Hydra lino where the
final act takes place and a113 also
shows up at the movie theater at the end
of the film and it's sneakily hidden in
the movie posters for dementia one one
three by the way the film playing at the
movie theater is also a reference to an
early 1960s Francis Ford Coppola movie
Edna mode and Jack Jack scenes are some
of the best parts of the sequel when Bob
goes to Edna's place where she's been
babysitting Jack Jack she mentions a
super-powered toddler likes Mozart which
is a nod to carry the babysitter who
mentions Mozart in the first movie and
also used his music in the short film
Jack Jack Attack hey also remotes have
to play when he leaps to make him
smarter because leading experts say
Mozart makes baby smart there's a very
clever poltergeist reference during the
Jack Jack cookie scene craig tea' nelson
who starred in the classic 1982 horror
movie and who's also the voice of mr.
incredible he is Jack Jack talking from
another dimension after he disappears
leaving a remote control behind
in poltergeist one of creatine elsens
children gets sucked into another
dimension by ghosts and similar to Jack
Jack the family can hear her voice from
the other dimension through their TV set
the Pizza Planet truck from the first
Toy Story movie is a regular Pixar
Easter Egg which has appeared in every
movie so far the only exception being
the first Incredibles this time around
though a period styled Pizza Planet
truck was specially designed to fit the
setting of the sequel this Easter Egg
was placed by sets supervisor Nathan
Ferris who notoriously made the Pizza
Planet truck and finding Dory almost
impossible to find in Incredibles 2
though the screen flavor is revealed as
being an ordinary pizza guy
so the Pizza Planet truck is likely in a
scene he appears in another regular
Easter Egg is a Chinese takeout
container this style of box is a very
specific design that recurs throughout
Pixar's films after first having
appeared in a bug's life where it was
called the Chinese cabinet of
metamorphosis and was used by Manny for
his circus act another Easter Egg which
supports the Pixar theory of a shared
universe is a billboard in Incredibles 2
for triple dent gum which is really hard
to spot but it flashes by during the
Elastigirl
train rescue scene triple death gum is
the brand of chewing gum from inside out
the jingle for which plays throughout
that movie the song from the gum
commercial sometimes we send that one up
to headquarters with a reason and there
was also a triple dank gum Easter Egg
last year in cars free with the brand
appearing as a car sponsor the recurring
Easter eggs of brands like Pixar Planet
and triple tank gum as well as the same
Chinese takeout box design lends support
the Pixar theory that all their movies
exist within the same universe the
mind-erasing device that Rick Dickey
uses to make Tony Ridinger forget
violets secret identity is the same one
who used to raise Carey's memory of the
baby superpowers in Jack Jack Attack
Incredibles to of course includes lots
of callbacks to moments and details in
the first movie where mr. incredible and
lasted I'll go to their meeting with Deb
tech they were the original costumes
they had before edna made their iconic
red suits and the last two girls new
silver suit and a last disciple both
have an upgraded version of the logo she
used to have when she was a solo
superhero
laughter girls darker sleeker design is
meant to be practical to help sneak
around in the shadows tracking villains
however when Helen complains that it's
dark and angsty she's also commenting on
modern superhero movies which have
tended to shy away from bright colorful
costumes at all dark in HD at the
incredible family's new house there's a
mug with a logo for ensuring care Bob's
old employer from the first movie the
waterfall that Elastigirl drives the
elastic cycle out of is reminiscent of
syndromes larval waterfall which also
worked as a hidden opening in the first
Incredibles movie plus I also got some
Batcave vibes from the scene and when
Elastigirl uses her body is a parachute
to slow down the speeding monorail it's
a callback to when she performed a
similar move on the monorail at
syndromes island hideout
the other big regular Pixar Easter Egg
is a famous luxo ball if you want to
spot that in this movie look out for
Jack Jack's cradle the luxo ball
appeared in Pixar's very first short
film look so junior together with two
desk lamps one of which is still used in
Pixar's logo as well as all the Pixar
references there are also some cool
superhero Easter eggs and in jokes and
Incredibles - when - says it's probably
a reference to Christopher Nolan's
Batman origins movie Batman Begins it's
not who I am underneath but what I do it
defines me some of the visuals in the
movie also felt that Man esque to me
such as how Elastigirl looks like she's
flying through the city like a bat and
these rooftop shots of Elastigirl which
reminded me of Frank Miller's The Dark
Knight Returns and also the Batman vs.
Superman movie following Pixar tradition
Incredibles - includes an easter egg -
the studio's next movie Toy Story 4
however because details of Toy Story 4
still sparse at this point Incredibles 2
sets supervisor Nathan Ferris has said
that the Easter Egg will probably only
make sense once Toy Story 4 comes out I
did spot what looks like a neon cowboy
hat during the helicopter rescue scene
which could be a woody easter egg or
perhaps a reference to a new Toy Story
character or location if you saw
anything else do let me know in the
comments The Incredibles 2 credits are a
joy to watch but if you didn't quite
stick around to the very end then you
may have missed a tiny little
he's a per possible sequel it's not a
proper post credit scene like you might
expect from a live-action superhero
movie but after all the credits have
rolled and just before the screen fades
to black a little image of the under-
drill pops up again this is a reminder
that the villain got away earlier in the
movie and that he's still hanging out
underneath municipal roads I want a
green light and Incredibles 3 there's
also a stack of secret cameos you might
had missed in the film singer/songwriter
uh sure makes a surprise cameo in the
movie as frozen's biggest fan and his
words in the sequel are also called back
to syndromes line to mr. incredible that
he was his biggest fan back him your
number one fan after all I am your
biggest fan this time around Rick Ditka
is voiced by Breaking Bad and better
call Saul actor Jonathan banks as but
lucky who previously voiced the
government agent passed away between
films John Ratzenberger who's voiced a
character in every Pixar movie so far
returns as a voice of the Underminer
the sons of Incredibles director Brad
Bird lent their voices to the original
movie and the sequel Nick bird who was
the voice of the tricycle kid in the
first movie and also voiced squirt in
Finding Nemo performed the voice of
monster Jack Jack and Nick's elder
brother Michael bird returned as a voice
of Tony riding her violets high school
crush signage in the movie also provides
a place for loads of secret shout outs
for other Pixar crew members this
Kristof billboard advertising bulgarian
overalls is a nod to Incredibles - art
director and Bulgarian born Antony
Christoph Pixar legend Joe ramped is
honored by the Joe ramped grocery-store
Ralph had an Oscar nomination as one of
the writers on Toy Story and before
passing away he'd worked on all of
Pixar's movies plus voiced various
characters Incredibles to story manager
Catherine Hendrickson's name appears on
a sign on the side of a building during
the under- sequence and current
technical art director at Pixar Michael
Rutter also gets a shout out via the
Rutter's every day repair a replacement
store in Mina Seberg there's also a
Domi's dally named after dome Ishii who
directed the Pixar short bow which plays
in front of Incredibles - now this next
one would have been a delicious Easter
Egg for Incredibles fans everywhere
two years too late Incredibles 2 was
originally going to be released in 2019
meaning it would have come out 15 years
after the original making that Syndrome
line fit perfectly
Pixar though had numerous problems with
Toy Story 4 so the two films dates were
switched around bringing the incredible
sequel forward one year a bitter blow
for lovers of that syndrome meme so what
other Easter eggs or references did you
spot and did you enjoy the sequel as
much as the original movie be sure to
let me know and make sure you're
subscribed for a chance to win an
incredible spunk Oh pop you can also
tweet me any comments or requests coming
up next two more Incredibles two videos
plus Jurassic world 2 and I'll link
those here on screen when they're ready
congratulations to my last Incredibles
giveaway winner send me an email from my
channels about page or tweet me so I can
send you the prize thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers